If you're a local business and you're
trying to get your website ranked higher
for local SERPs and dominate your local
SERP ranking like this case study, then
continue watching today's video. So, I
went ahead and I created a Claude code
skill that allows you to essentially put
in your website, the local area which
you're trying to dominate, and then
we'll go ahead and give you a full local
SEO audit. So, for this specific site, I
put in the website URL and the area
which is Toronto and Niagara Falls. And
we see that we can get a score out of
100 based upon how good we are currently
in terms of the local SERP. So, this
website off- obviously has
some work to do. We get the top five
priority action items. So, build
dedicated pick up landing pages, fix
um your home page page title, add local
business schema, FAQs, and some content
hub. So, quick wins of things in which
you could do right away, and we also get
a competitor gap analysis. Now, if you
go ahead and use this skill, all right,
so here is the full skill description
here on the right-hand side. This skill
actually also uses the Google Trends
data to ensure we're getting live and
up-to-date information, and it's also
going to go out and use Chrome to do
live um
data scraping from SimilarWeb and
Ahrefs, so the information is actually
up-to-date. So, again, if we go back
over to our report here, we can see your
competitor gap analysis. So, key
strength and their weakness is and
opportunities. We see search demand
right now, so we can see for this
specific niche, search is at the
highest. We see programmatic local page
strategy. So, we see 16 pages that we
need to build out with the target URL,
the primary keyword, why um we need to
go after this specific local area, and
the competition level. So, for these
specific pages, instead of actually
telling Claude to generate each one of
these pages, because if we do so,
Claude's limits will will 100% be
completed. So, you will burn up your
Claude tokens very, very easily if you
want to generate these
pages, especially if you're writing long
in-depth content. So, that's why we've
combined our Claude skill with Word
Rocket. So, you just connect the Word
Rocket MCP over to Claude. It's very
easy to do so. Just head over to
settings, connectors, and enter in the
URL wordrocketapi.com.
You need to have an agency level plan
that has MCP or API integrated. And once
you do so, you'll then be able to
connect your Word Rocket account
straight over to your Claude account.
So, I can then tell Claude, based on the
tier one topic, which is
Niagara Falls tour from Mississauga.
Right? So, this is the tier one article
that we need to write here. I can tell
Claude to use this topic, write the
article. So, based upon the article
details that Claude has generated, use
Word Rocket to write this full article.
And we can see here, it went ahead and
used our Word Rocket set up. Right? It
went ahead and fetched the article, and
then went ahead and posted the article
directly over to our site. So, I can go
ahead and open up this link, and we can
see that the full article has been
posted over to our site. Now, of course,
we can go ahead and we can improve this
content, but the main point is is it was
actually posted as a page. So, with the
Word Rocket integration, you can
actually post as a page, not just only a
post. So, if I can see here, this went
directly over to my website, right? Not
as a blog post. So, we can automate
generating our content using Word
Rocket. If I head back over to the Word
Rocket dashboard, I can see here this is
the article with our images. This is the
full
full page here that we have. And every
page will be unique, and every page will
be generated um
with the instructions that Claude gave
us, and we can post this all directly
over to our site. So, not only are not
only can we automate the local SEO audit
and get actionable insights that we need
to do, we can automate our content
writing. So, we can see here there's
about there's about 50 new pages that we
need to write, and we can easily easy go
ahead and do so. So, you can see the
audit actually gives us the full page
details that we can then simply just
tell Claude to use Word Rocket to write
the full article, and we have an
internal linking plan as well. So, we
can even add this into Word Rocket for
the additional instructions and tell
Claude to use that to write the full
article. If you guys would like to
dominate your local serp and get access
to this Claude code skill, just comment
the local below and I'll send it over to
you. Hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video. I'll see you in the next one.